hello everyone it's seven o'clock this
is sky news breakfast
more travel misery for holidaymakers
this morning as gatwick airport
announces it's going to be capping the
number of flights during the summer
because of staff shortages it comes as
the boss of heathrow tells sky news
it'll take 12 to 18 months to get the
industry back to pre-pandemic levels
we'll have more on that throughout the
show
and temperatures have been running high
here in westminster with the pm facing
yet another bruising week so what might
the forecast have in store for the
government ahead of two important
by-elections
lots to talk about when i'm joined by
the business minister paul scully in
just a moment
it's friday the 17th of june
more travel disruption as gatwick
airport caps its summer departures while
the boss of heathrow tells sky news
it'll take some time for the industry to
get back to normal i think it'll take 12
to 18 months for the whole industry to
get all of its capacity back to where it
was before the pandemic
boris johnson will today meet with a
group of tory mps from the north of
england as he looks to alleviate
pressure on his premiership and the cost
of living
parts of the uk are set to hit 34
degrees today as the hot spell reaches
its peak
people at this west london lidar are
hoping to cool down with it forecast to
be hotter here today than in the
caribbean
a warning that the government is set to
miss its targets for clean air as it
struggles to tackle harmful pollution
new evidence given to congress details
how former president donald trump put
his vice president mike pence in danger
while illegally pressuring him to
overturn the election
also coming up this morning marked by an
atomic era we'll hear from some of those
affected by britain's first nuclear
testing experiments and hear how they're
calling on the government to honor
survivors
[Music]
an amazing 80 years of paul mccartney as
the beatle prepares to celebrate his
birthday we'll look back at his life
with his brother mike
[Music]
hello anna very good morning to you
gatwick airport has announced it'll be
reducing the number of flights during
the summer holiday period due to staff
shortages britain's second largest
airport will cut the number of flights
from 900 a day to 825 in july and 850 in
august
this comes as the head of heathrow
airport told sky news that air
passengers could face disruption for up
to 18 months a skies business
correspondent paul kelso reports
for some travellers the jubilee was no
cause for celebration as cancellations
and delays at airports turned the
holiday into a weekend to forget
heathrow avoided the half-term chaos and
they're confident they'll do so again
this summer when numbers peak for the
school holidays though the boss admits
it will take time for the whole industry
to recover from covid well i think it'll
take 12 to 18 months for the whole
industry to get all of its capacity back
to where it was before the pandemic and
that's not just uh across the uk it has
to be across europe as well because we
are affected by staffing issues at other
airports around the world
and so this isn't quick
very skilled jobs have been lost and now
we're having to as an industry recruit
people back train them up again to be
able to serve passengers and that just
takes time
it's very easy to slam the brakes on the
industry lead to enormous job losses but
it's much harder to scale it up again
when you suddenly open the doors again
the airline industry was perhaps the
most ravaged by kovid 19 ending
international travel at a stroke wiping
out billions of pounds in revenue and
the return to normal has not been easy
the real test of how their coping will
come
in a couple of short weeks once the
school holidays and the summer travel
season begins in earnest
at bristol airport passengers queued
into the car park last month
to avoid a repeat they're on a
recruitment drive to fill more than 100
roles including security where training
remains a challenge
it can take up to 12 weeks to go through
security and training
but we are able to do some training
ahead of the actual start
and the issue of the past so we're
working around it as best we can
the real test of the industry's
confidence and passenger patience is
about to come
paul kelso sky news at heathrow
well the small business minister paul
scully is here with me very good morning
to you and so much to talk about this
morning but i do want to kick off uh
with more travel chaos as we're
outlining this morning at the boss of
heathrow airport as you heard there
saying that that kind of disruption
could last for 18 months at gatwick
airport reducing the number of flights
over the summer period
should airports have been better
prepared
well i think we knew that the uh the
travel industry as a whole was already
really hard pressed through covid and as
you heard john holland kay there say
that when you start of anything almost
from scratch because there were very
very few fights going through heathrow
at some points that it takes time to
come through and we and upskill uh um
the staff bring the staff back in so
our ministers transport ministers have
been trying to work with um heathrow
gatwick or the other airport operators
we do want them to do more we want to
make sure that in a tight labor market
there are enough people to uh to staff
the roles there and we'll continue to
work with them but you've got sympathy
with them you think that they couldn't
have planned this any better well i'm
not on the detail in terms of of their
day-to-day planning as a business
minister rather than uh
a transport minister but uh but it is it
is difficult we've seen this in other
sectors to
that idea of scaling up again having had
uh almost mothballed the economy for two
years um but in in
travel and airports it's so so important
because not only do you we need to
reinstall investment and travel from
international travel coming in but as
you say there's that pent-up demand for
people to go as you go out for the first
time there's so much demand i mean
people have had a miserable time haven't
they for many people this is their first
holiday they've had for years and if
they have the prospect of it being
cancelled and having to rebook
with inflation at
nine percent at the moment they're gonna
have to pay more for another holiday so
what can the government do to help well
this is why we want to work really
closely with the airports andy and the
um the airlines as well to make sure
that they are doing everything they can
and and see what more we can do from uh
organizations like the department for
working pensions our work coaches to
make sure that in a tight labor market
where people
um can work more hours if they if
they're able to uh and really matching
up so that's the answer is that people
have to just work hard
well
what i mean is that the uh there are a
record number of vacancies 1.3 million
vacancies across the country in all
manner of sectors but um there are also
people who have recalibrated what they
want to do when they're on furlough and
we want to make sure that those people
that are not necessarily working
full-time um
through universal credit we can we can
get them back into to work to be more
productive if that if that suits them
and obviously match them up with it with
the sectors where there are those
vacancies okay it sounds like you are
saying you want people to work longer
hours and well i want you what i'm
saying i'm not we're not talking about
going out and forcing people to do
anything but they just want to make sure
that they're matched up properly so that
it's just got that those people who can
work longer that want to work longer can
work can be better matched with the work
coaches and work closely with their work
coaches how bad is this going to get we
saw the bank of england raising interest
rates for the fifth consecutive month a
warning of more rises ahead inflation
they say could go up to 11 percent how
bad is the situation are we heading for
a recession
well i think what you what we are saying
we do we're trying to do everything we
can to tackle the cost of living uh
issues this is a global situation you've
seen inflation in other countries in
america and other european countries um
hitting similarly high figures and and
forecasts so we've got to do everything
we can to weather that storm the
chancellor has put in 37 billion pounds
worth of support and what you see that
um the 650 million pounds that's going
to a number of um households will be
hitting their bank accounts on the 14th
of july it's not enough though you'll
see the national insurance threshold
changes actually giving it delivering a
tax cut next month as well so we know
about that package but there needs to be
an overall economic strategy doesn't
there i mean these these changes
obviously will will make a bit of a
difference but not enough of a
difference or so what what you saw the
chancellor do through throughout um
kovid you saw him flex as as he saw what
was happening on the ground the feedback
that was coming back and uh
and tackling the very best data and
forecasts and he's doing a similar thing
now as i said he's put 37 billion pounds
worth of immediate relief to especially
for the most vulnerable in our society
anything we need to do fiscally around
tax uh tax changes that that that gets
done in the autumn budget so that
there's
we'll make sure that we're listening
looking and responding
what about help people with mortgages i
mean they're seeing interest rates go up
is there anything that you can do to
help people out who are on variable
mortgages or looking to buy a house and
get a new mortgage well i think in terms
of uh you know buying a house and
and taking new mortgages people need to
obviously do do their own calculations
and and work with what they can what
what they can afford but as i say in
terms of existing householders and and
people's everyday bills the chancellor
will look and respond accordingly what
we can't do the government he's already
said he's absolutely right the
government can't solve every problem
within this he's not going to be able to
save every business and and work with
everybody's uh individual costs but
we'll do everything we can within that
within the remit of keeping public
finances um tight as well because we're
actually servicing our debt national
debt having just put 480 billion
eight billion pounds into the economy
we're paying something like 85 billion
pounds just to service our debt not to
go to schools hospitals we've got to
keep that running as well yes a lot of
people think about their own personal
debt of course what about tax cuts i
mean this just isn't the environment for
tax cuts is it with inflation looking
like it could reach 11 well that's what
i mean about the chancellor looking at
everything holistically so come the next
budget he will have to look at the
balance but what do you think should
happen richie sunaka said that that tax
cuts aren't on the cards now do you
think that's the right i think you know
we are in that low tax government i
would like to see taxes
at the moment well no because i say
we've just put 408 billion pounds into
the economy you know that's my general
principle and the party's general
principle is to have low taxes to trust
people to spend their own money the best
way we can but as i say we've got to
keep the nhs we're going to get the
backlog dealt with in the nhs we've got
to keep our schools well-funded all of
those
those things in the finance public
finances it's a complex situation and
having put all that money in
the chancellor can look when it comes to
the budget and make his decision at that
point
but you think no tax cuts is the right
way forward for now well what i don't
want to do is write a budget months
ahead of the uh of a budget i'm just no
announcements on tax cuts there won't be
tax cuts now because as i say that will
be any taxes that are dealt with a
budget in the autumn there's so much so
much to go until we get to the autumn
and uh you know things can change in in
any number of ways okay i want to to
move on to the resignation of lord guide
and boris johnson's ethics advisor
he released his or rather the government
released his resignation letter
yesterday
can you say in the light of that without
doubt that you believe that the prime
minister boris johnson is a man who
upholds the highest standards required
of his office yeah i i can i think he's
been clear in um
in his approach and uh
uh regarded to the fine that he received
i think lord guyt um seemed to have
resigned on um
the discussion around when the prime
minister asked him for advice for um uh
for supporting uh our industries in the
in in the next few months the steel
industry just to be to clarify well
that's that's what i understand from the
letter just see
reading the letter i've not been part of
of the discussion but i read the letters
as they were released that was my
understanding about it now clearly those
kind of discussions if there aren't
you know i wouldn't want to speculate
because that's obviously commercially
sensitive stuff but uh um but but that's
i i have no more knowledge than that but
that seems to be where lord guy has
finally taken his decision but
nonetheless in terms of the prime
minister's behavior you know he uh
rightly wants to draw a line under the
the so-called party gate because people
are uh worried more about what you've
just been talking about the cost of
living the what's going to mean to their
mortgages and their bills um in the in
the days and months ahead they want to
feel that their prime minister is
ethical too don't they and
how will they view the fact that he's
lost two ethics advisors in very quick
succession and lord gait the last one to
go has said in his resignation letter
that the prime minister put him in an
impossible and odious position this
isn't someone who who speaks out in this
kind of language normally
doesn't that point does that point to a
prime minister who's got the highest
ethical standards well i think my
understanding of what i read when i read
the letter was that that was talking
about advice that he'd asked him to give
not about not about the impossible
yeah which which i can't i can't really
reconcile myself because that was about
advice he
he's asked him on something else rather
than uh what's happened around around
partygate but in in terms of the the
fine the prime minister received
sue grey talked about leadership uh
within number 10 and the cabinet office
and there's been a raft of changes in
number 10 and the cabinet office in
terms of organization in terms of
changing that culture changing that
ethos and sugue herself said that she
wants that that needs time to bed in law
guy was clearly very frustrated with the
whole way that that was handled as well
so will there be another ethics advisor
that i don't know i mean there was a
there's a number of questions that uh
lord guy has has raised about the way
that uh the the way that that system
works and that's right that number 10
actually takes time to just um look at
that and work work that through so um
that'll be for them to announce would
anyone want to do the job it looks like
anyone who does the job is overruled by
the prime minister no well it's as i say
that i think that's but that's part of
the uh the the the consideration is is
is how the system works and uh because
we want to make it um as efficient
uh to you know working as as best we can
and um that's what the prime minister
number 10 will consider would you be
comfortable if there was no ethics
advisor what kind of message do you
think that would send down what what i
think i would be comfortable with as
long as there is a mechanism there needs
to be a mechanism clearly that the the
prime minister and that me as a minister
are held to the to the highest standards
there is a ministerial code there and we
want to make sure that um that it's
adhered to because that's the principles
that we all stand on not just as mps
when we first come into the house but
when we accept officers of state as
ministers do you think they should go to
parliament do you think this is
something that mps more broadly should
decide on and make sure that there's a
truly independent ethics advisor to keep
the prime minister and the government in
check i think the you know it it's
difficult because you then get into
positions where um you know government
government governs and parliament
scrutinizes that parliament would
undoubtedly continue to debate this so
this matter but i'm not sure that uh the
the that day-to-day running of
government you know the government is
beholden to parliament in that sort of
slightly in in that balance of power as
it were that's so in our unwritten
constitution i'm not sure that's how it
works we've had an extraordinary week in
politics this week haven't we and we've
had
the bill on the northern ireland
protocol we've had the rwanda policy
seeing uh flights uh grounded
by a court in
in europe does the prime minister think
he can breach whichever rules he wants
and get away with it because the
european commission vice president
told our political editor
that constant breaching of international
law by the country is damaging uk eu
relationships
that unfolds just a repeat of sort of
negotiating in public that we've seen
over the last few years i mean i don't
believe
the government's been really clear that
the legislation that we've introduced
doesn't reach international law but
nonetheless actually it's there as an
insurance policy anyway what would
rather have is a negotiated settlement
with the eu we don't want to end up in
trade wars and and escalated disputes we
want to make sure that we can work
together because this affects both sides
and so if we can have sensible
conversations um rather than as i say
negotiating via the media or via social
media and these kind of things that
that's far far better not just for both
sides but for the businesses that are
caught up in this as well okay paul
scully we appreciate your time this
morning thanks very much indeed for
coming in thank you
so let's take a look now at the morning
paper shall we and the telegraph leads
with the bank of england predicting
inflation will climb to 11 later this
year prompting the chancellor to
indicate that tax cuts will be put on
hold
the bank of england raising its interest
base rate to the highest point since the
start of 2009 is also on the front of
the metro with the headline 11
hell is on the way
the eye also leads on inflation
rocketing to 11 as ministers rule out
personal tax cuts until 2024.
fears over rocketing inflation and tough
times ahead also makes the front page of
the daily mail
boris johnson is considering scrapping
the role of ethics advisor after the
resignation of lord guide that makes the
front of the guardian
so there's your morning papers let's
tell you what's going to come on the
show later this hour i'm going to be
joined by the leader of the liberal
democrats sir ed davey
labour's shadow attorney general emily
thornberry will be on the programme soon
after eight
a nato summit is set to take place in
madrid later this month with ukraine
high on the agenda the spanish foreign
minister will be with me to discuss
those talks
now britain is set for its hottest day
of the year so far with temperatures set
to hit the mid 30s in some areas the met
office is describing the temperatures as
rare for june and has issued level three
alerts across the east and southeast of
england well the heat is spreading up
from europe where it's even hotter with
areas of spain set to hit 41 degrees and
wildfires emerging in the northeast of
the country
france has also been gripped by
record-breaking temperatures with french
weather services reporting 40 degrees
being hit for the first time ever in
june and highs of 39 degrees expected in
southern france today
and it's in the south where it will be
the warmest here
well skies saber chowdhury joins me now
from alido in west london it must be
very tempting to dive in saba and the
temperatures rising already i guess out
there
good morning honestly i cannot keep up
with the weather uh in this country but
what i do know for sure is that places
like this lido are going to be ram
packed
later today and also at the rest of the
week we're talking about hotter than the
maldives and jamaica for goodness sake
with temperature in london going up to
34 degrees celsius that's also in east
anglia and in places across england and
also wales we're talking between 27 to
30 degrees celsius making it potentially
the hottest day
of the year so far but with severe
weather warnings
we do also uh have heads up from some
official body so the london fire brigade
for example have said that there are
increased
chances of things like fires at local
playgrounds
parks even in gardens at home and also
we have health experts warning that
weather like this brings it with it
disrupted
sleep uh impact to you know cognitive
performance and also
increased hospital rates for a mental
illness now weather like this is rare
but it's certainly not
unprecedented and with climate change
we're looking at potentially more days
like this
saber thanks very much indeed and uh
maybe get in the shade that's my little
bit of advice very helpful saber thank
you
so let's take a look at some of the
other headlines now and a report
from the national audit office has
warned the government is not on track to
meet its air pollution targets by 2030.
it also found that the public are not
being effectively informed about the
issue and that large parts of the road
network aren't in line with pollution
limits
the head of the uk's armed forces has
said russia has already already
strategically lost the war in ukraine
admiral sotoni radekin also said that
although russia may achieve tactical
successes in the coming weeks any notion
that the war had been a success was
nonsense
the united states says it's aware of a
photograph appearing to show two
americans captured after going to
ukraine to fight russian forces
alexander drewkey and andy quinn both
from alabama have been missing for a
week and their families fear that they
have been captured
the capital riot committee has heard
evidence that donald trump called his
vice president mike pence a wimp during
his last ditch efforts to overturn the
2020 election result the committee also
heard that mr trump was repeatedly told
that his plan to overturn the result was
illegal
the lead republican negotiator in the
u.s senate's effort to agree a
bipartisan gun safety bill walked out of
the talks yesterday following hours of
negotiations the lead democrat however
remained optimistic that lawmakers could
vote on legislation before the senate
left for a two-week july the fourth
recess
now a new service launches today that
allows deaf people to communicate with
999 operators using sign language
previously deaf people had to text
emergency services in english which for
many is a second language
skies madeleine ratcliffe reports
if you think of an emergency there's a
good chance this comes to mind
however for the 12 million deaf people
in the uk there's no siren to say help
is on its way
and making that 999 call isn't easy
but today a new service launches for the
thousands of deaf people who use british
sign language or bsl ambulance please
my dad's had a stroke one click of a
button on the app connects users to a
bsl interpreter via video link
through them they can talk to a 999 call
handler in real time
until now deaf people have had to ask
others to call for help or use a
text-based system
this will be faster but that's not all
the biggest difference it's going to
make is to give deaf people
the independence
um
to make those kind of calls themselves
in a language which they are most
comfortable in and when you're
distressed
you need to be able to communicate in
your own language and not be trying to
think of
how to communicate in a different
language
because english actually isn't the first
language for many deaf people british
sign languages so imagine trying to call
an ambulance in french when you don't
speak it and then trying to get all the
medical information you need across as
quickly and accurately as possible
that's the situation bryony found
herself in when her husband suffered a
severe allergic reaction out on a run i
wasn't able to ring 999
and i thought about texting my mum to
ask her to call 999 but then i thought
that's going to take too much time and
then relaying the call
so i was really panicking my husband
couldn't breathe and he was in and out
of consciousness
bryony had to drive her husband to the
nearest hospital to seek help
happily he survived
this service could save others the
stress brownie went through and save
lives
madeleine ratchcliff sky news
well as we've said it's going to be hot
today let's take a look at the forecast
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well today brings the peak of the heat
with 34 degrees celsius or 93 fahrenheit
possible in the southeast
england wales and the south of ireland
are enjoying a very sunny start but
further north there's more cloud with
rain in places and for many it's fairly
warm already england wales will hold on
to the strong sunshine through the
morning albeit hazy at times most places
there will turn out hot very hot in the
southeast but sea breezes will cool some
coasts
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
and now a quick reminder to be careful
if you're out in the sun today i'm sure
no one needs to be told that but new
research from the consumer group which
has found that mineral-based sunscreens
costing up to 28 pounds have failed to
provide the level of protection that
they state on their packaging the
watchdog said that none of the five spf
30 products they tested offered the
level of production a protection rubber
claims that's worth knowing
now coming up on sky news breakfast i'm
going to be joined by the leader of the
liberal democrats sir ed davey so do
stay with me
[Music]
let's remind you of our top story is
here this morning and the boss of
heathrow has told sky news it'll take
more than a year to fix staffing issues
as gatwick cuts its summer flights in an
attempt to limit further disruption
[Music]
boris johnson will meet with a group of
tory mps from the north of england today
as he looks to alleviate pressure on his
premiership and the cost of living
and temperatures are expected to hit 34
degrees in parts of the country on
what's forecast to be the hottest day of
the year so far
so let's get more than on our top story
now and gatwick is cutting flights over
the summer months to limit disruption
for passengers well earlier the business
the minister for small business said
that airports are facing a challenging
situation ramping up businesses
following covid restrictions but paul
scully also said the government wants
the travel industry to do more to ensure
that services run without disruption
when you start up anything almost from
scratch because there were very very few
fights going through heathrow at some
points that it takes time to come
through and we and upskill uh um the
staff bring the staff back in so
our ministers transport ministers have
been trying to work with um heathrow
gatwick or the other airport operators
we do want them to do more we want to
make sure that in a tight labor market
there are enough people to uh to staff
the roles there and we'll continue to
work with them there are a record number
of vacancies 1.3 million vacancies
across the country in all manner of
sectors but um there are also people who
have recalibrated what they want to do
when they're on furlough and we want to
make sure that those people that are not
necessarily working full-time um
through universal credit we can we can
get them back in to to work to be more
productive if that if that suits them
and obviously match them up with it with
the sectors where there are those
vacancies
well our political correspondent ron pal
is here with me morning to you um so
many cost of living pressures around at
the moment and then added to people's
misery this news about more travel chaos
at our airport so what did you make of
what the minister had to say about that
absolutely i think after two years of
covid spiraling prices people will be
looking forward to a little bit of
escapism and the news this morning
warnings of industry problems for 12 to
18 months gatwick talking about
cancelling flights as well i think what
i took from what paul scully was saying
there is that in the short term anyway
there's not a lot the government can
really do because a lot of the problems
here are being caused by people leaving
the travel industry during covid um and
leaving gaps essentially
inside airports inside airlines as well
and it's difficult to fill some of those
gaps in the short term ahead of summer
he talked a lot about using work coaches
and job centres to try and match people
up with jobs i think that will only
solve the problem to an extent and
actually from what we're seeing from
gatwick
it's inevitable that there is going to
be some sort of disruption and canceled
flights in the months ahead broadly on
cost of living um as well
and in the same vein paul scully
admitting that the government cannot
solve every problem and so and save
every business in the coming months so a
fairly stark warning there and on that
question of tax cuts which i think the
prime minister is going to be hearing a
lot about um at a conference he's
attending in the north of england to
speak to northern tory mps many of whom
won the seats in 2019. many of those
want to see tax cuts i thought paul
scully sounded very very cold on that
though talking about the chancellor
looking holistically at where we are he
said that we are a low tax government of
course as you pointed out to him they're
not a very low tax government at the
moment and then on that difficult
political question of the standards and
ethics advisor resigning i thought it
was quite interesting that paul scully
seemed to suggest he would be
comfortable if there wasn't any
standards advisor as long as there was
some sort of mechanism in place i think
realistically given everything that's
gone on in the last six months it would
be a very difficult look for boris
johnson to pull off if he doesn't
replace lord guyt interesting to see
where that one goes rob thanks very much
indeed
well let's stick with politics shall we
because uh the leader of the liberal
democrats sir ed davey joins me now um
david welcome to the program thanks very
much indeed for talking to us let's kick
off shall we with our top story today
and the news that uh the boss of
heathrow is mourning of disruption for
18 months in the travel industry uh
gatwick airport is also scaling back on
the number of flights that it's putting
on
over the summer months
what can be done about this
well it does look like a summer of
discontent and a winter of chaos with
the government we've seen the problems
at gatwick uh and heathrow at other
airports uh we're seeing flights
councils the government are failing on
passports people i've got lots of
constituents who've applied for
passports and have not had responses
after months so there's a real chaos in
government the government should have
started months ago
helping and working with the transport
industry
they failed to respond positively to
many of the transport industries
requests particularly helping to get the
staff we keep hearing about so the
government have acted too late uh and
frankly um that the chaos we're seeing
in part in the passport sectors made it
even worse
well
the government says that it is working
with the travel industry and what
specifically would you like them to do
well we've known for some time and the
transport industry was saying to the
government months ago that they needed
to work with the industry to find people
to to do the jobs
and whether it's working with them on
trying to recoach people trying to bring
them back to coax them back the
government made it worse they've
increased taxes on the lowest paid so
for example they've frozen the income
tax allowance that means that some of
the low paid up are now being dragged
into income tax and that reduces the
incentive to work
they've cut a universal credit which is
supposed to help people back into work
so when we've got a cost of living
crisis with interest rates going up with
prices food and petrol prices going up
the government been raising taxes on the
very people who would be needed to fill
the jobs uh at our airports and we're
hearing it on the doorsteps as we
campaign people are fed up with this
government making the problems worse
you you talk about the problems of
raising taxes but cutting taxes is
inflationary and the bank of england
said yesterday that inflation could go
up to 11
we don't want to make that worse do we
well first of all liberal democrats have
argued that we need taxes to go up on
the oil and gas companies so we can pay
for a tax cut a vat cut of 600 pounds
which would really help people who are
struggling we need to cut taxes on
people who are struggling and it is
frankly i don't really buy this
inflation argument much of the inflation
is coming from
abroad because we're seeing the um the
rise in energy costs and we're also
seeing the failure of the government to
invest to get the growth if we had a
growing economy actually would be of
supplying the goods and there wouldn't
be this problem of inflation the
government is making such a mess of our
economy we're seeing inflation go up
we're seeing growth go down
and you know people say well it's
happening around the world well
other countries are struggling that is
true but it's far worse in the uk if you
look at the growth figures and growth
projections the uk i'm afraid to say
is the worst in the developed countries
within one exception of russia that is
how badly this conservative government
is handling the economy so just to be
clear your solution is to cut taxes and
to increase spending
now for the key thing is the tax cuts
because people need money now they're
really struggling with high few
food prices higher petrol prices in
interest rates going up so people need
some help now that is the key thing and
the government could balance that by
making sure the oil and gas companies
really pay a fair share that the tax
they brought in really isn't anywhere
near
enough and so how big should the taxes
be then on the oil and gas industry if
the government's plans aren't adequate
we were posing something twice as large
as what the government proposed just to
give you a size a size of it um and if
we can get that money we could a make
sure that there's no danger of inflation
because you're taking money out of very
wealthy shareholders pockets and you're
putting into the pockets of people who
are struggling people who would do the
jobs at gatwick and heathrow if it was
worth their work you know we really have
to have a fair approach to our economy
which will get the growth that we need
and help people with the cost of living
i think the government have completely
lost their way
and it's partly because they're not
focused on the needs of ordinary people
they're focused on saving boris
johnson's skin we see it day in day out
of parliament
okay and i want your thoughts before we
go on lord guy's resignation the ethics
advisor to the prime minister his
resignation letter was was published
yesterday what did you make of it
well we have a prime minister who's
broken the law
who's lost now two
ethics advisers people supposed to
advise him what is right and wrong you
have to draw your own conclusions and we
know he's broken the ministerial code
you know one really felt sorry for law
guide uh having to work with the prime
minister who's not fit to be uh the
prime minister of our country and just
don't take my word for it we are
knocking on doors in a by-election in
tev in devon in tibetan and honeton and
people just want to see the back of
boris johnson um if we could win that
it's going to be i think a quite a close
run thing uh back in that down in devon
but if the liberal democrats could do
what we did a year ago when we took a
chunk out of the blue wall uh in the
shock wind we had in cheshire amazon in
buckinghamshire if we could do that in
devon um that would really i think see
the back of boris johnson
okay um so ed davey we appreciate your
time this morning thanks very much
indeed for talking to us thank you
so let's get more then on what's been
yet another tough week for the prime
minister i'm joined now by the head of
political polling at opinion chris
curtis a very good morning to you
so um
it's been quite an extraordinary week
hasn't it for the prime minister once
again last week of course which feels
like an age ago we saw the vote of
confidence
but this week we've had a number of
different uh policy announcements uh as
well as lord guys resignation so where
has that left at the pm's ratings yeah
it's quite interesting i mean there's
not very many weeks for the prime
minister that aren't quite strange i
think and we do seem to have quite a lot
of this going on and it's been going on
for some time but however dramatic this
may seem to us actually a lot of the
polling we've seen over the past past
couple of weeks has shown that uh we
haven't seen much more of a shift in the
prime minister's ratings at all if
anything he might have slightly improved
his position and the reason for that is
because the public made up their mind on
boris johnson quite some time ago they
thought he lied about partygate they
don't trust what he has to say and
further resignations by an efforts
commissioner votes of confidence but
from the conservative party they're not
going to change anyone's minds boris
johnson's approval ratings have fallen
quite dramatically and at the moment he
isn't doing enough uh to bring those
approval ratings back up again and is
there any indication of what could
improve those figures
i think what people liked about boris
johnson the reason that they voted for
him in that 2019 general election is you
know he wasn't the most trustworthy
person in the world he wasn't the kind
of person you'd buy a second-hand car
off but he was the kind of man who would
get things done and i think he needs to
go back to that position of being seen
by voters being seen by the public being
seen by those people in the red wall as
the kind of person who can get things
done once again and at the moment you
know given that the biggest problem
facing voters in this country is cost of
living rising energy prices he isn't
seen to be getting anything done uh by
voters to help them on on that really
crucial issue yes it'd be interesting to
see what the government plans on that
score but he's also known as a survivor
isn't he i mean at what point could that
reach a tipping point well i mean
lots of people would argue that we've
probably passed that tipping point if
you look at the prime minister's
approval ratings they are the kind of
approval ratings that you don't normally
come back from it'd be very rare for a
prime minister to come back from them
that doesn't mean to say that boris
johnson isn't going to be the exception
but he would be the exception if he
ended up sort of bouncing back and
winning the next general election given
where he currently is another thing that
makes things more difficult is that he's
lost the trust of voters you know over
six in ten voters say that they don't
trust the prime minister now when people
don't don't trust you it's very hard for
them to listen and to believe anything
you say so it becomes even more
difficult
to turn that kind of polling around so
he's in a very difficult situation i'm
not saying it's impossible for him to
come back but i think it's going to be a
real challenge for the conservatives to
come back under boris johnson and of
course he would argue that lots of the
challenges that face the government at
the moment the challenges that are faced
worldwide in terms of pressures on the
economy and the cost of living i mean to
what extent
is this personally being put at his door
all those kind of pressures that people
are under
you know i i think that's a fair point
and voters are
actually fairly forgiving of things that
uh you know outside of a prime
minister's control we were sitting in
focus groups during the pandemic for
example and lots of people would say
boris johnson made mistakes but he was
in a very hard situation and we do still
hear some of that now but i think it's
clear that uh people are a lot less
willing to give the prime minister the
benefit of the doubt than they used to
partly because of party gate partly
because of all the sort of scandals that
have surrounded the government and
that's why you know the prime minister
is finding it so much more difficult
with the cost of living crisis than his
was with those other issues that came
before but but as a general rule if
people end up feeling better off does
that make them more sympathetic towards
the government absolutely i think this
is ultimately the government's biggest
problem is that we're about to go for a
year where most people in this country
most swing voters most people in every
constituency are about to feel
significantly worse off that's going to
be a difficult situation for the
government um you know
at any point but when the government's
going into that situation with a prime
minister who's lost the trust of the
british public it's going to be
incredibly difficult indeed what about
labour how are they doing are they
managing to to take advantage with the
electorate of some of the prime
minister's problems well i think it's
it's certainly true that the uh that
things are
a lot worse for the conservatives and
they are good for labor so when you when
you when you ask voters for example a
range of questions who do you trust on
the economy who do you think would make
the best prime minister on on whatever
question you ask the conservative score
has gone down quite dramatically the
labour school's gone up slightly but
nowhere near as much as the conservative
score has gone down so labour still has
a lot of work to do kiostama still has a
lot of work to do to convince voters
that they're ready for government you
know significantly more people tell us
still that labour isn't ready for
government than is ready for government
that kiyostama you know doesn't doesn't
at this stage look like a prime minister
in waiting so there is so much work that
labour needs to do to turn those numbers
around still they can't rest on their
laurels they can't just see the
government that's in a really difficult
situation and assume that that means
they're going to end up in government
interesting stuff fascinating times
chris curtis thanks very much indeed
for sharing your wisdom with us this
morning we appreciate it